good to see everyone welcome to my talk
called bird song as code so logistically
I should just explain I'm going to be
giving this talk from within Vim with a
closure reppel running overtone in the
background so if those words don't mean
very much to you don't worry it should
be hopefully fairly self-evident what's
actually going on um but if you're into
functional programming and lisp and
things like that you might are that
interesting so just quick demonstration
you can see this line here that I'm
highlighting um what lisp does is it
puts the function as the first argument
so that says multiply 220 by 3 uh by um
over2 and I can display the result here
uh I could also
add it's 550 uh and the reason I'm
picking those two operations is the
great theme of this talk will be the
difference between addition and
multiplication so we'll get there later
the other thing that's a joke but also
true uh the other thing I can do is cuz
lisp is not a pure programming language
is that I can execute side
effects right so I just executed a bit
of code that uh played some birds on
which is the subject of this
talk so I think there's two things that
hopefully I can convince you of that
will allow you to appreciate this talk
the first is that bird song is
worthwhile taking seriously as a musical
study so the music theory of bird song
is something that's interesting the
second thing I need to convince you of
is that using computer code to represent
music theory is something that actually
elucidates the subject and it's that
second point that I'm going to start
with so if you look at these two values
here right we have one which is I'm
calling raw and the other one I'm
calling computed they are actually
extension their extension is equal right
so if I execute code that says are they
equal it says true right so you could
say in some sense those are the same
value but if you look at them they're
not constructed in the same way and I
would argue that the second one the
computed one goes a lot further in
explaining what's going on with that
value right so you might look at all
those numbers and if you spend a little
bit of time looking at it you might be
able to see that like there's 1 one
there's two two there three threes and
you might be able to reverse engineer
what's going on but if you look at the
computation here it kind of lays it out
so this says we've got the range of
numbers of one to or 1 to 7even because
it's not inclusive we map a function
that repeats each number n times and
then we can catenate everything together
so I'm from the school of thought that
says that if you can structure a
computation around a value and it does
so successfully in code that is shorter
than the original value that represents
some kind of achievement of
understanding so if we can do the same
thing as using Code as a notation for
music or for bird song specifically that
allows us to to think about uh that we
might have exploited some of the
structure or understood it one of the
nice side effects is that if you want to
change the
value and you've structured the
computation successfully the change you
want to make is probably natural in
terms of code so if I only want uh even
numbers here I can I can do so and I get
that that result right and it's easy to
do if I had to edit the raw value that
would be kind of finicky and you would
your attention would start to wander uh
while we're doing these
things so that's the first thing maybe I
should also mention like there are
alternative ways of representing music
right this is a spectrogram so you can
see things directly there's all sorts of
things you can see in this
representation that you can't see in a
code representation there's also all
sorts of understanding and of the the
way it's structured you can't get um um
maybe even one other example um this is
Western music notation of a piece of
bird song and this representation is
great in one way because it allows a
person who knows how to read this
notation to engage with bird song but
it's also opaque in other ways and maybe
something this notation does is it
imposes a particular expectation for
what features of Music are relevant to
the
viewer and with code we have the luxury
of developing new sub routines new ways
of dividing up logic as we need
it so back to the
code so the the academic subject that
I'm relying upon for this talk is called
zoo musicology and it's not really well
established it's multidisciplinary it
kind of is a bit IL defined um but
effectively it's the study of Music in
animal culture right so there's uh
musicology is the study of Music Theory
ethnomusicology is the study of music by
people with a ethnicity which I guess
theoretically should be everyone but in
practice it's not used that way uh and
zo musicology is for people who are not
human right uh and the two sources that
I'm really going to be relying upon for
this talk are a book called is bird song
music by Hollis Taylor where she argues
that we should see birds not as
specimens not as scientific subjects but
as collaborators as colleagues as
artists and a scientific paper called
overturn based pitch selection in hermit
thrush song which is a little bit more
as the name suggests uh scientific but
it the nice thing about this is it
provides a theory and a structure that
I'm able to apply to the uh content of
the book right so the two birds will be
focusing on the well mostly the pi
butcher bird monus which is a an
Australian song bird using Theory
derived from the hermit thrush which
North American people might be aware of
is pandemic to this
area
so there is a question about whether
bird song is music that I actually don't
think is very interesting but I feel
like I have to engage just a little bit
to defend this talk right so there are
some people who see music and art as
somehow essentially human and so they
often seek to draw boundaries that
allows Human music to count as art but
doesn't allow whale song bird song or
you know other Creative Expressions by
the animal kingom to count as art so
they might say uh something like ah but
uh a human musician is able to create
and Vary what they're doing whereas a
bird just plays the same thing every
time it's not actually true but people
still say it birds can can vary right uh
I've I've read people say ah but a bird
is instrumental about its art bird song
sounds like music but actually what's
going on is the bird is just trying to
attract mates right and I think if
you're familiar with the way music
exists in human culture you might say
that's if anything something that's very
consistent with what we're doing so I I
I take the I don't like the
anthropocentric approach I think the big
difference maybe is scalability right so
human beings do have ways of
transmitting our culture that birds
don't so you know bird bark didn't have
anyone to write down what they were
coming up with bird Billy Holiday didn't
have anyone to make recordings of their
Awesome song so well birds do teach each
other and song birds about half of the
bird kingdom rely on having other birds
to learn from in order to become song
birds I think it is true to say that you
know bird culture doesn't it's not the
same as human culture but we should
still I think look at it respect it and
find it interesting and I think probably
most of the differences just like this
scalability transmissibility difference
most of the differences between birds
and humans can be explained through the
material circumstances of of birds so
you you can you can treat it as
interesting and equal without trying to
pretend that it's the
same uh but really the biggest argument
in favor of bird song being music in my
mind is just I don't really want to be
the kind of person that listens to bird
song and thinks that's not music right I
think I think it's more axima to me
right so if someone said is bird song
music I think the most powerful way of
uh convincing them is just to
[Music]
play and if you listen closely you might
actually hear that variation principle
right it was the the same song three
times but each time the bird developed
it more that's a pied butcher bird
here's a hermit thrush for
completeness right so I don't want to be
the kind of person who doesn't think
that's music so I will treat it as
such uh so to start with in order to
discuss the differen between human and
bird music uh I need to start with the
commonalities right so I'm going to
start with physical properties of sound
and then later move on to the
differences so what this uh two line uh
definition does is Define a synthesizer
that just emits s
oscillation uh at at a given frequency
so this is what it sounds
like oh sorry a bit loud um and you can
see that if I make the frequency
High the sound is higher right so sound
is a pressure wave that goes through air
and the higher the frequency the higher
the
sound now so far what I played you just
briefly there is something that just
continues over time right there's no
event but we know that when we listen to
music notes happen at a certain time and
and that dimension of time is part of
how it
works so uh the next stage that I need
to talk about is shaping notes so when
we do this in synthesizes we often talk
about envelopes so what envelopes are is
a a signal that controls how loud the
note is and that includes the original
point when the note the attack of the
note begins and it gets louder and gets
to it's maximum volume and then when the
note closes out as well so this line
here says um Define me an envelope that
takes 3 seconds to get loud and 0.9
seconds to get soft again this is what
it sounds
like so it kind of Fades out right uh if
I were to make this a bit more
percussive by shortening the attack it
sounds a bit more Chim
likee oops let me just re-evaluate
it
right by the way uh I uh whenever I give
music coding talks I always remember the
advice of a a really strong talk Giver
she's given some talks of strange Loop
and her advice is never give life coding
talks and the reason being is that she
says that there's uh there's too much
risk it's too easy to lose the audience
right so hopefully you'll indulge me
here um but there is always some degree
of risk when you're typing code in front
of an audience that you'll type
malformed uh s
Expressions now this is another
interesting property of sound and I'm
going to say the simple generalization
first before problematizing it which is
that fractions sound good right so when
there are frequencies that are kind of
in a a whole integer relationship they
sound like they're harmonizing so if I
play these two sounds at once we get a
kind of a harmonizing effect um and you
know maybe I can change this and
get different ones right so when you add
those two signals together the lowest
common multiple of the frequency is uh
the frequency of the combined Soundwave
so when these things have a nice ratio
this the combined sound wave though it
has various like wheels and stuff to it
it repeats over a short and
understandable
period again now the reason that I have
that asterisk and I don't quite want to
say that fractions sound good is it's a
little bit of a category error right so
so far I've talked about physical
properties of sound but sounding good is
something that exists only within a
particular culture with a respect to a
person's taste so the ratio of um four
on three was actually in medieval Europe
regarded as a
dissonance I don't think modern people
would regard that as true and it's kind
of the ratio of four and three is the
basis of the first chord change that is
really distinctive about blues music so
there is definitely an interpretive step
that determines whether resonant
actually translates to good the other
thing I want to show you is that it
doesn't have to be exact right so if I
almost get the ratio of four and
three it's kind of still pretty good uh
maybe let's go
405 it's a little bit wobbler if you're
a good musician you might start to hear
like the the wobbling
there and if I go I don't know to
415 that's a bit sour right to our taste
right and that's to our taste because
it's entirely possible that's a kind of
effect that would work within a given
musical context so it's pretty lucky
that it doesn't have to be exactly
accurate because if it had to be exactly
exactly accurate we wouldn't be able to
do it right but it's also worth bearing
in mind that there are these little
little differences still get rounded out
and generalized and our brains can work
out kind of what's going
on
so I've simplified a little bit uh what
is going on with real sources of sound
so I said that a sound wave is a single
frequency but it's actually more true to
say that it's a series of frequencies so
there's a fundamental frequency but then
another frequency that's twice as high
with half the wavelength normally comes
out of most real physical sources of
sound and another one that's three times
another one that's four times Etc so the
bottom one the fundamental frequency is
the loudest and the the one that
determines what pitch we hear the note
as but there's actually multiple things
going on at once before I play you it I
want to actually do a physical
demonstration of this I'll step away
from the mic but hopefully you'll be
able to see what's going on right so
imagine this Slinky spring is like a
guitar
string
right right so that's the fundamental
frequency but let's see if I can get one
of the harmonics out of
it
right so that's the next one let's see
if I oh thank you thank you thank
you I think I can probably do the third
one as well but uh because the higher
harmonics take kind of more energy and
they're softer um it's harder and harder
to do that so I'll see if I can do
[Applause]
it all right so let's get back to the
coding so this
synthesizer um this has one sound here
at the base frequency one times
frequency then we've got a * 2 * 3 * 4 *
5 and for each one of them I'm basically
making it softer um so it'll still sound
like kind of artificial and synthesize
alike but it should also sound kind of
Fuller like there's more to it so this
is the the non-harmonic one and this is
the harmonic
one let's maybe make it higher
so when there's real sources of sound
when you're hearing an acoustic guitar
when you're hearing anything that's made
from resonation in a physical um
resonance in a physical uh space in a
tube in a string that's what you can
likely to
hear right and just before I go to the
next section I just want to note that
I've seen I've shown to you two
different principles for having families
of frequencies right so this one here I
could call linear so we have a
fundamental frequency then double triple
Etc so each step is the same number of
Hertz the other principle I showed you
was uh ratios I said that ratios that
are simple and understandable sound good
so that's where why I said earlier that
we're going to talk about addition and
multiplication because those two
different principles of generating
possibilities of sound are very relevant
to the music
theory so the exponential
scale uh is kind of how modern human pop
music works so if I can EXP explain it
in code with the exponential scale we
start with a fundamental frequency which
is like you know maybe the song is in C
maybe it's in a whatever that determines
the starting point and then we multiply
it by stacked 12th roots of
two right so uh this line says defines
the 12th root of two and this just says
we multiply the fundamental by the 12th
root of two to n so maybe I can um just
show it on the keyar I
think
right so we see we've got this
instrument here so it's a like a piano
keyboard so the difference between these
two sounds is called an octave and it's
a doubling of
frequency or harving because I'm playing
it the other way around and you can see
there's actually 12 jumps in
[Music]
between right so that's where we get the
12th root of two from right so each one
of these each one of these adjacent
buttons represent
ratio is like about 1.06 something like
that um and so no matter where we are
the relationship of a note to its
neighbors is based on this this
ratio that's just uh player scale an
exponential Scale based on
[Music]
that right so it sounds roughly like a
normal scale for those musicians in the
audience yes I did play both the major
and the minor 7th so it's kind of more
of a a bbop scale than a normal one um
I'm doing that for a reason of
comparison later so if you understand
what I'm talking about then give
yourself a thumbs up but you don't need
to right um so let me just Rune the
Keeton much easier than a physical
instrument and we can move to the the
bird version which I'm calling the
linear scale because I'm trying to avoid
kind of musical jargon so the linear
scale works like our harmonic series
before right so we start with a
fundamental frequency and then as we
walk up we just multiply everything by n
so if the fundamental frequency is 100
Hertz then what we have is 100 200 300
400 1,000 1100
Etc and so uh let me play that for you
and it's going to sound similar but not
exactly the
[Music]
same right so there's a couple of notes
that might without without necessarily
knowing what's going on sound a bit sour
to you and that's because of your
expectations being based on the 12th rot
of two system right there's nothing
inherently wrong or incorrect about
those no those numbers and in fact those
numbers are in some sense more pure
because they're based on integers and
not based on you know irrational
fractions to make it easier to compare
though I can play the two of them at the
same time because there's one thing
we're good at it's hearing the distance
between two frequencies um so uh
uh let's play the expon if you can read
this these three lines of code let's
play the exponential scale with the
linear scale at the same time and you
should hear some notes sounding really
sweet together and others sounding
really
[Music]
clashing right I think what's remarkable
about that is not that there's clashing
but there's any that kind of work well
right so what why why would that be the
case that we've got this like 12th root
two an irrational number we've got this
other system that's linear why why would
they line up at all uh let me just play
[Music]
again and the answer is that the 12th
root of two system is really good at
approximating some whole Noma fractions
not so good at others but really good at
some of them so if you take four steps
on this
keyar those make uh what you might call
a major third if you're into music
Theory and it doesn't make exactly the
ratio but it's close enough that we can
we can figure it
out so let me just evaluate this so I'm
just taking a random scale and I'm uh
getting the ratio between four steps so
let's evaluate
it so it comes to 1.25 992 right that's
almost 1.25 that's almost a a a pure
thing so it's close enough that we get
the point um I think we even get a
um even better approximation if we go
seven
steps uh does anyone know what seven
steps is
maybe so it's almost 1.5 right 1.4 98 so
with this system of of approximation
it's good enough that we can make these
harmonies happen uh so uh that's why we
have some frequencies that line up and
that the the bird linear scale and the
human exponential scale have enough
similarity that we can uh we can see
that they're
compatible now something that human
beings do and I think we can speculate
as to why but we have something called
octave equivalence so that means that if
we play a Melody twice once where every
frequency is doubled we hear it as kind
of the same thing a second time right so
in the same way as that 10 a.m. one day
is the same in a sense of 10 a.m the
next day there's kind of this cyclical
pattern that's something about how we
interpret music um so that's partly why
this octave this doubling is really
relevant because each time you double
you get into an equivalent of the same
space um you might speculate that that's
due to the uh different voice ranges of
human beings where we have you know
people of different singing ability and
that if they want to sing the same thing
at the same time are different sizes
means that you need somehow to have an
equivalence between two different ranges
um but I don't think I don't think we
know that for sure but let me play just
the start of a children's
Melody once and then once where if you
see at the end of the line there I'm
adding 12 to it so I'm going up 12 steps
on the
[Music]
Keeter right that second one it's
clearly not the same thing right it's
way higher but it also clearly is the
same thing in some way right there's
some kind of equivalence you can hear
that there's a pitch class equivalence
to use the the drgon maybe I can even
make it clearer if I play them at the
same time
right that sounds like you know you
might call that singing in unison right
it's not the same pitch but because of
octave equivalence um it's almost the
same now why am I talking about this
because this is a human thing it's
because it's believed that birds and
other animals don't have octave
equivalents so maybe they don't have
that same uh difference in range of
people of the species that they need to
be compatible or maybe they just don't
have the same practice of singing
together that we do but it's something
that birds don't have and maybe if you
think about this linear scale it might
also make sense because the exponential
scale where that's 12th root of two is
highly symmetric wherever you start you
can go up and down and you have the same
ratios whereas the linear scale is not
like that so the difference between 200
300 Hertz is very different than the
difference between 1600 and 7 and 1700
htz right the fraction between them is
different um so so perhaps again that's
why birds appear to not not hear that
equivalence
uh now I talked about a human Melody so
I should make sure that I'm uh equal
here with our bird colleagues and uh I
want to mention something that is called
the species call of the pied butcher
bird so there's this particular three
note series that butcher Birds
incorporate very often into their song
and the nice thing about it is it kind
of marks them out so if you're in the
bush and you're trying to work out
whether it's a pi butcher bird or a
similar bird this species call is kind
of a genre marker you could say now they
don't Echo it exactly the same each time
it's kind of more of a a motif that they
can improvise on but it's it's very
present so here's my synthesized
version right and you can see that I've
just done this by picking out the
harmonic series the 18th the 18th and
the 16th harmonic of the fundamental
frequency which I'm specifying as 130
here now let me play some real butcher
bird sound and and um it's this clip is
deliberately chosen because it has heaps
of species called spliced together but
among kind of normal notes you'll keep
hearing these kind of notes in various
[Music]
forms right so they kind of like shoot
up higher than the rest of the notes and
do that so that's a distinctive feature
of kind of the genre of Pi butcher bird
song I'm calling it the species call now
I want to also not just automate that I
want to I want to show you something a
bit more complicated so this is uh audio
24 as it's known because it's uh in the
uh the book is bird song music there's a
whole series of audio clips and this
audio 24 is one of the ones that Hollis
Taylor discusses uh she makes the clips
available on the Internet by the way
which is quite nice for really
appreciating what's going on so the way
that that I'm going to put this into
code is I'm going to take a raw version
which just has kind of you know exact
fractions to many decimal places of the
sound and I'm going to override the
pitch with this harmonic series model
right so I'm going to say the first note
is the 11th harmonic 11 times the
fundamental then the 10 times 10 * 12 *
12 9 9 8 Etc then I'm going to actually
insert the species call in there because
that appears so when I weigh back at the
start said that writing things in code
can illuminate understanding you can see
this is demonstrating that those are not
just random notes but they're the
species Co um and I'm going to play
first I'll play maybe I'll just play the
the bird version and then I'll play them
uh my version and the bird version
together so you can hear whether or not
you think it's an adequate model so
here's the bird
[Music]
version right so that's just a pi
butcher bird and here it is is uh
sounding a bit like Steve R different
trains I think with the synthesizer
version over the
[Music]
top right so you can kind of hear that
it's close it's not exactly right um but
that's the thing about these kind of
models that show understanding they
don't have to be lossless in order to
illustrate something right so I think
it's I think it's it's close enough to
be interesting right um but not not uh
not exactly right so I'll just Play It
[Music]
Again species
cool
right so uh the scientific paper about
uh overtone based pitch
selection uses a much more numeric
method to compare whether or not their
model is is working so they kind of take
the differences between what their model
predicts and the actual pitch and square
that so it means that the further apart
the sounds are the kind of of the bigger
it shows up so I haven't done a rigorous
analysis of the pi butcher bird song In
This Way um I guess you could if someone
was bored and wants to follow up the
code at home um but I have done just
kind of a rough thing to show you so if
I um if I use the exponential scale like
the human scale the average difference
squared comes to 942 and if I use you
don't need to know the unit or anything
um and if I uh do the same thing with
the linear uh it comes to 563 so small
is better and basically the that
exponential scale I'm arguing at least
for this very cherry-picked example um
is a better is a better
approximation uh right I want to say a
little bit more about
uh not just looking at as birds as
specimens because uh in the original
version of this talk I I ended with that
kind of difference of squares analysis
to kind of defend my my model and I
realized that was a very hypocritical
note to end on right because because I
was treating bird song in a kind of a
cold non-collaborative way I was
treating it like a regression puzzle um
I was treating it like I was just
modeling numbers and not like I was
treating them like you know like
colleagues or artists like that um so I
wanted to do a little bit more kind of
blending of what musical practice would
look like uh between bird song and
humans so what we have here is a mapping
between keys on the keyboard and linear
notes as the uh as the pi butcher bird
might sing them so one thing I think is
kind of cool to see out here is that so
if you think X is an unmapped note that
if you look at the very low notes so
each one of these horizontal lines
represents an octave it represents 12
numbers um there's only one note that I
can map to a pied butcher bird in the
first line then the second line there's
two numbers right because the second and
the third harmonic appear in the second
octave then there's four numbers so it's
doubling each time
there uh eight numbers and as you get
into the higher octaves we now have the
opposite problem where in the lower
pitches we have buttons that if you're
playing bird song on the kear don't do
anything and later on we have this
problem where there aren't enough
buttons because there's so many
harmonics that fit between a doubling of
the frequency right so between 10,000
and 20,000 Hertz well that's a doubling
of frequency that's that's an octave in
our music but there's a lot of harmonics
of a sound that would appear in there
but still um I'm going to try something
so uh uh I think um was it Czech off who
said in the play right that if you bring
a gun to the First Act of a play you
have to like fire it by the third act I
think that probably also applies to kear
so I'm going
to I am going to try playing that but
also but also what I want to demonstrate
is the kind of the interest and the
difficulty in playing with this scale
because there's um there's some things
that work really well because there's a
really nice uh resonant even ratios you
can get out of playing in the birth
scale because it's based on the harmonic
series which is nicer than kind of our
conventional pop one um but there's also
just like kind of notes that are missing
so if you're playing in C major just
talking to the Musicians for a second
like there's no kind of f or a that's
acceptable within the normal range right
so you can't kind of make the normal
cords or
harmonies but even working around that
I'm going to try and indulge myself in
something and do a little bit of a a
collaboration with birds uh and the
other thing I want to show is that at
least so far I've I've had this Paradigm
of where I'm working from examples right
so I'm not um I wasn't um uh integrating
a whole bunch of bird song together I
was saying here's one example I'm going
to treat it kind of in isolation and
play it and think about it then I'm
going to have another example and I'm
going to have another example that's not
really how bird song works in the wild
right we have the we don't have the dawn
soloist we have the dawn chorus right
you're out in the bush you're hearing
lots of different birds in different
directions they're also like not tuned
together so in a human Orchestra right
everyone you hope is tuning their
instruments to be the same so that
starting point of the scale whether it's
130 htz or 440 Herz or whatever the
convention is they all agree on that
same convention that's not something
that's practical within the material
circumstances of birds out there because
you know you're hearing one person who
one other bird who's 20 M away another
that's 100 away Etc so I'm going to play
try playing a few Birds together as well
as um playing the kear with it and I'm
not going to try to imitate the bird
song I'm going to try to maybe fill in a
bit of the the Gap in what birds do so
uh you know Rhythm Harmony bass these
are things that are very prevalent in
human music but birds for practical
reasons aren't really that into so I'm
going to try to I'm going to try to kind
of kindy to do that bit right so let's
see if it uh if this works I'm going to
start a loop
up you can hear that one that I was
synthesizing before
[Music]
right
up it off
[Music]
d
a
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
thanks very
[Applause]
much